hello I'm Justin razis and today I'll be
talking to you about our work
asynchronous multi-party Quantum
computation this is a joint work with
FIFA guile tender lujang and Joelle
Rivera
in multi-party Quantum computation a
number of parties want to perform a
Quantum computation on their Quantum
inputs
at the end of the protocol each party
gets its own output
for security no party should learn
anything about any other party's input
even if they arbitrarily deviate from
the protocol
for example they might decide not to
send certain messages
there's been quite a bit of work on
designing secure multi-party Quantum
computation
the first work on this area achieves
statistical security and guaranteed
output delivery as long as less than
one-sixth of the parties are corrupted
follow-up work improved this threshold
to the optimal one-half threshold for
statistical security
later work considered the dishonest
majority case starting with the special
case of two-party Quantum computation
this work achieves computational
security with a board
it was later generalized to multi-party
Quantum computation where all but one
party might be corrupted
further work improved the security
guarantee to identifiable abort
another work achieved a constant round
protocol although they only achieved
security with a board
however all of these protocols have been
in the synchronous Network model
even in the classical setting real world
networks cannot guarantee synchrony
since Quantum networks are more General
than classical ones we can't expect to
solve this problem when we eventually
construct real world Quantum networks
this leaves open the problem of
constructing secure multi-party Quantum
computation in asynchronous Networks
in the synchronous model
all messages are guaranteed to arrive
within a fixed amount of time
if party D does not receive party C's
message on time then it knows that party
C never sent the message in the first
place
however even the classical setting real
world networks do not provide this
guarantee
even worse synchronous protocols often
fail catastrophically as soon as even
one message is delayed
a more realistic model is the
asynchronous network model
in this model there's no guarantee when
a message will arrive only that they
will eventually arrive
as a consequence it is impossible to to
distinguish between an adversarial party
which never sent a message
and that honest parties whose messages
just haven't arrived yet
let's say that there was one corrupted
party but no one knows who
after receiving messages from four
parties you can't tell whether the last
party will ever send you a message so
the protocol has to progress
this means that in the asynchronous
setting the impacts of some parties have
to be ignored
asynchronous Protocols are even more
difficult in the quantum setting
in particular since States cannot be
duplicated the no cloning theorem rules
out Quantum broadcast
which is a crucial tool for enabling
classical asynchronous protocols
in this work we study the feasibility of
quantum secure computation in the
asynchronous network model
on the positive side we show that
asynchronous multi-party Quantum
computation is possible as long as less
than one-fourth of the parties are
corrupted
furthermore we show that this result is
tight
asynchronous multi-party Quantum
computation is completely impossible if
any more parties are corrupted
interestingly in the classical setting
the optimal threshold is one-third
as we can see here our protocol has
statistical security and guaranteed
output delivery
I'll start by discussing the feasibility
result
our protocol follows the traditional
secret sharing based outline
first each party shares their input
using a protocol called verifiable
Quantum secret sharing
intuitively verifiable Quantum secret
sharing ensures that the parties hold a
well-formed secret sharing at the end of
the protocol
or else they all know that the dealer
tried to cheat
once valid Shares are distributed the
parties can evaluate the circuit gate by
gate using standard techniques
finally the parties send the output
shares to the appropriate party
similarly to Prior work the primary
technical difficulty is in constructing
verifiable Quantum secret sharing
a verifiable Quantum secret sharing
scheme has two phases sharing and
reconstruction
at a high level if the sharing phase is
successful then all parties have a valid
share
otherwise all parties know that it
failed
additionally if the sharing phase is
successful then the reconstructor should
always output the same Secret
note that it's not allowed to fail in
this reconstruction
similarly to Prior work we'll start by
building a weaker primitive called weak
Quantum secret sharing then we'll use
this to later build verifiable Quantum
secret sharing
in Weak Quantum secret sharing the
reconstructor is also allowed to Output
a special failure state
as a starting point let's consider weak
Quantum secret sharing in the
synchronous setting it turns out that is
enough to construct it just for zero
States using this the parties can
construct an epr pair and send one half
to the dealer
then the dealer can teleport their share
their secret into the other half of the
epr pair which is still shared amongst
the parties
we will be able to use a similar trick
in the asynchronous setting as well
in Prior work we Quantum secret sharing
for zero States uses three steps first
the dealer splits a zero State into
several shares and authenticates them
then they send the authenticated shares
to each party and send the
authentication key to a classical
trusted third party
distrusted third party can be
implemented using any secure computation
protocol for classical functionalities
this is done a total of two Lambda plus
one times where Lambda is the security
parameter
finally the parties perform some local
computations and measure all but one of
their shares
they send the results to the trusted
third party who runs a test which checks
that all of the shares that each party
held are for a zero state
to reconstruct the parties send their
authenticated chairs to the
reconstructor and The Trusted third
party sends the authentication key to
the reconstructor
if the dealer was honest then this means
that the corrupted parties cannot tamper
with their shares and the reconstructor
can safely reconstruct
on the other hand if the dealer was
dishonest then the corrupted parties can
change their shares During the
Reconstruction phase
however the honest parties still hold
valid shares
and in this scenario they hold have
enough shares to uniquely determine the
reconstructed value
now let's move to the asynchronous case
recall that in this setting the protocol
must progress with only n minus t
participants since if the T corrupted
parties never sent a message they can't
be distinguished from an honest but
delayed party
in the picture party one share is
delayed by the network
the classical approach to solving this
problem is to agree on a core set of
parties who received correct shares
these parties can be expected to
contribute During the Reconstruction
phase
since this is an agreement on a
classical value
we can use the classical trusted third
party for this
unfortunately there are some issues with
this approach
after we remove the one party who didn't
get a share there are only four parties
left to participate in the
reconstruction
however one of these parties might be
adversarial
and they could withhold their uh share
from the reconstructor this means that
the reconstructor might only receive
three shares
of course
we can't distinguish this case
from an honest party which
is just delayed when they send their
shares
so this means that of the three shares
that the reconstructor receives
one could still be adversarial
if the dealer is dishonest then the
corrupted party knows the authentication
key and can change their share without
being detected
this means that the reconstructor would
receive two correct shares and one
incorrect share
the threshold for a Quantum secret
sharing scheme must be over one half
so this incorrect share might change the
secret
this means that for safety the
reconstructor must always output failure
in the classical setting this issue is
addressed by having every party sign the
tested shares during the sharing phase
this will prevent the adversary from
changing shares later even if the dealer
is dishonest
unfortunately Quantum signatures are
impossible
to make matters worse when the dealer is
honest and the same situation occurs
reconstruction must always succeed for
correctness
to deal with this we introduce a new
primitive called weak Quantum secret
sharing with weak termination
weak termination allows the
reconstructor to hang forever if the
dealer is dishonest
it is worth noting that although we
build verifiable Quantum secret sharing
from this primitive
our verifiable Quantum secret sharing
protocol will still have the normal
termination property
our Insight is to build a late checking
mechanism into the protocol which allows
parties outside of the core set to
contribute
this is in contrast to current classical
asynchronous protocol techniques where
only the parties in the corset
contribute
in the picture the dotted lines denote
old messages
everyone except Party 1 is moved on but
party one still gets to check their
share
to allow this we show how to implement
an expanded trusted third-party
functionality which allows it to
interact with just a single party
if the dealer is honest then eventually
Party 1 will get a correct share
after it checks the share with the
trusted third party it can send it to
the reconstructor
in particular this means that every
honest party will eventually send a
share to the reconstructor
because there are n minus t honest
parties the reconstructor can just wait
until it receives n minus t shares which
in this example is four
recall that previously it had to proceed
after receiving only n minus two t
shares which is three in this example
it is important to note that late
checking does not change the case for a
corrupted dealer since the delayed
honest parties might never receive the
shares in the first place
using weak Quantum secret sharing
protocol we just constructed we can now
build asynchronous verifiable Quantum
secret sharing
as before is enough to just verifiably
share zero States
we'll use the two-layer approach from
prior work
first the dealer splits a zero State
using a standard Quantum polynomial
secret sharing and they send the shares
to each party
then each party shares their level 1
shares again using weak Quantum secret
sharing with weak termination
when we later try to reconstruct the
level on shares any level 1 shares
belonging to corrupted parties might
have the Reconstruction hang forever
third the parties test their shares by
performing some measurements and sending
the results to a classical trusted third
party
if the shares all pass the test then
there are all valid shares of a zero
state
the sharing terminates as soon as n
minus t parties have valid shares
to reconstruct the parties do the
Reconstruction phase for the wheat
Quantum secret sharing scheme in order
to help the reconstructor can
reconstruct the level one shares
as soon as the reconstructor has at
least n minus 2T level 1 shares it can
recombine them to get the secret
note that because of weak termination
the reconstructor might never manage to
reconstruct the level when shares
belonging to the T corrupted parties
which receives shares
in fact it doesn't even have to fail it
could just hang forever when
reconstructing those shares
this is why the threshold for
reconstruction is n minus 2T instead of
n minus t
however weak Quantum secret sharing
still prevents the corrupted parties
from changing their level 1 shares
they're only option is to withhold them
this means that it is always safe to
reconstruct with the minimum number of
shares which is just over one half
for more details about the construction
please see the full paper
I'll now discuss the impossibility
result
we will just focus on the verifiable
secret sharing functionality
we want to show that it is impossible to
achieve verifiable secret sharing for
even 1 4 Corruptions by standard
arguments is enough to argue and
possibility for four parties and one
corruption
intuitively we can show that a
verifiable Quantum secret sharing scheme
for this scenario implies a Quantum
Erasure code which can correct two
errators in four shares
if they did then we could clone Quantum
states by encoding them into four shares
and then reconstructing the state using
two sets of two shares each this would
give us two different copies
let's imagine a scenario where the
dealer is corrupted and does not send
any share to party three
during this party 2 will also behave
honestly note that party 2 here is
corrupted
if Party 3 is sufficiently delayed then
party 1 and Party 4 will assume that
party 3 is not sending messages
and they won't detect that party 3 never
received a share in the first place
then during Reconstruction the corrupt
Party 2 can just withhold their share
and stay silent
at this point
Party 3 doesn't have a share to
contribute so parties one and four
uh must be able to reconstruct the
secret
however this would correct exactly two
out of four shares
uh which would violate the impossibility
for Quantum Erasure correcting codes
thanks for listening you can find the
full version of our paper on the iacr
ePrint server